housing gun breath my my name is bad man
welcome back there live I kill him well
that's a [ __ ] larette's damn scared
me do it
I got a shot ebro's throats rats what
are you doing I got a shot my man
welcome back to condom what are you do
it well he shot him
Hey what are you doing Oh
how does he shoot back ha save the time
hey man hey man do you want a story
enjoy your story in your chefs that made
no out still [ __ ] me
cool that guy had a gun I want this gun
what is it I saw he had a gun ah [ __ ]
gotta get this wooden oh fletchie Sam
Tai Chi everyone here is [ __ ] out
stop shooting me stop shooting me
everyone here is crazy how can you hit
me from there stop it stop it hey you
want a friend here's the deal name is
sledge e that's right
ok the plan here is to Pikachu and
sledge and
blockage and blechy and block it I don't
date ring Oh epic budget down so die
mister [ __ ] take the ribbon
don't hit me I don't like being raped oh
I'm supposed to finish it
there we go oh no I broke e oh I'm so
sorry I didn't mean to do it
ah [ __ ] that's not a good start at all
god dammit alright let's see if we can
find some clues over here
hey I'm that bird I'll call you Harry
all right let's take photos of secret
plans that's right that's right a
Madrasi all the legs like a blueprint
from but numbering subway passenger card
okay so you fellas registry shoes mine
was the city's contractor for the cars
years ago yeah I haven't seen one of
these number eight cars and years what
is number that red circle area all right
I was swimming for that [ __ ] Oh with
the sledgehammer there's a close-up out
whoa sorry sorry about that
alright zum-zum zum-zum zum-zum
gotcha haha now what you want the circle
part red ballpoint pen highlights a
searing compartment in the car
Thomas they generally seal the doors of
these suckers shut when they go out of
commission rhobar my work past hole try
the cars tool cabinet under the frame
once inside the car I'm that compartment
alright I'll do that I'll do what the
lady said I'm not gonna argue with her
first healthkit cat first aid julian
Nickerson Oh Julia sweet Julia let's go
in here
more dead birds I guess Oh No Oh what is
this - I hate this flashback Oh sir ah
ah ah it was a [ __ ] head
dude right crowbar has clues on it
excuse my laser gun boom I shut that
[ __ ] past on the end of the crowbar is a
common plaster mix limitation particles
mixed in with the da star I'm a soft
finish you pinkish party store dummies
did you consult
nothing no SAP crow at Carl let's go and
open the subway thing like I opened your
mom last what you you kind of charge me
with that thing
hey man not cool I took it from you it's
mine now haha mad or block oh hey sorry
[ __ ] down and tell you with your own
weapon
hey you last year you are ugly ugly I
wish you keep that on man hey times have
to stun you know stop doing that
what are you did it go where did it go
oh I'm sorry I didn't mean to do that
hey man let's try number 3 a snap watch
ha ha ha ha I broke his neck alright
let's get to know ha you will know
you'll never have my pill ank man wait
actually you can have it cuz I need a
crowbar but it's a funeral it's romantic
now they will be together forever so I
guess we use the crowbar on this thing
that's where I understood it yes
maybe here
No maybe here no and why why I think
what did she's like my dad why I'm sorry
let's keep oh I need more health packs
give me that [ __ ] wait we went in here
we took the crowbar we're gonna use the
crowbar on the subway I'm a shootout or
Taylor for no reason and goddamn you're
out of shape man you're out of shape
like I was in the corner
um maybe know if there's another subway
tat oh maybe this this into the jet yeah
hot chocolate tears crow I hear someone
you want to [ __ ] with me I [ __ ] you up
[ __ ] oh that's right they run away
every works every time wait there was a
secret investigating alright time to
shoot my look for jizz alright got a
footprint
check the thought of that right again no
I gotta be there we go
alright pretty cool come on I can make
my own shoes 3d shoes even oh that's 40
it's all pattern matches Badgers of what
where protector pattern I'll run a fire
search locally but you can get these
anywhere fairly common there's some
schmutz in the pattern troughs probably
same plaster dust as before uh uh
okay I get I get it I get it man
I was it though where was it I don't
even [ __ ] remember there's something
in the ceiling oh there it is
no that not it maybe over here no where
the [ __ ] was the footprint I was like
here okay well mannequins
I hate mannequins god transfer data one
right all right so I'm gonna help
transfer data what
take another footprint yes
no that's not it
that's not it either what am I supposed
to take photos up mannequins really you
wanted me to take photos of mannequins
but fine I'll do it
there we go smile it's not smiling don't
know why what the [ __ ] man
transferring penis when ready I don't
get it why don't we just go up there oh
there we go that's a clue that's a clue
for shizzle says Bart's
let's them submitted a new arts
department store oh just a minute [ __ ]
six four five Burnside went out of
business 14 years ago the squatters
group took it over almost immediately
and now it's not what you would call
prime shopping territory I think since
the matchmaker would be there a good
source of mannequin parts but then
what's all this here an outpost a second
shop I should probably go down there
all right just decide okay [ __ ] the cops
don't even drive down Burnside unless
they have to
it's a nasty area filled with nasty
people everywhere is nasty what's the
problem beyond the beyond nasty
I didn't do anything Oh Thomas root 16
to burn side that train will take you
directly to the department store buy
hurry I'll just make it aa but I am so
out of shape whoa whoa what onion yeah I
don't want to do it fine I'll save you
I slave you I block it I don't don't
trick me man don't trick me che go up
here
I caught okay I convenient that he fell
down there I'm happy about that all
right
hey man you like the heck hello
[ __ ] you hit two earlier just sip it
slap it
whoa whoa sup it bear how you been doing
out there way too good oh you changed
everyone everyone just keep changing sex
all the time that's cool I saw a lady
running up there hey man are you okay
yeah there's so much it oh [ __ ] you
don't scream like I do
[ __ ] you [ __ ] now are they
nope nope nope nope where is he
what the [ __ ] did I do what I kill
anyone crazy I guess I join them
hey Dee says how the guy hey don't run
away from me with a black man oh [ __ ]
whoa where did he get that oh [ __ ] my
life
don't die I can't die damn it
sneaky black people you are dead
don't say that birds dying from god damn
it you bad shape up man you better shape
up cause I need Emma Hart is 10
oh I need to use the booth more I think
it's probably a night
hey what is that just oh why do I block
there hey
two at a time Oh give me the gun go lock
it
give me the gun did he took it don't
take my revolver bro later we get your
power block it Oh slap in the face like
it's 400 messmate [ __ ] oh nice block by
block - hey block it oh oh oh what you
gonna do
oho I'll give you a number four I can't
click it
ah [ __ ] you edek showed up right when I
kill stupid-ass house sup Jesus well you
look like a lion
you look really angry man that's a
problem man you forget to eat your
breakfast
you need your breakfast man you need
that [ __ ] [ __ ] here here's the camping
flatbeds or you lost your feet back it's
like whatever I love my poor give you
number four hey man
oh that's right
face reconstruction time
all right keep going we need to get on
that train how it's right see how your
dad Oh
someone took AXI oh we're going back
that's why I remember this we went down
here
I think it yeah that's why there's
already a bunch of dead people I guess
and a whole bag Thank You Kristen is
which way are we going but we already
were in the subway
this really doesn't make that much sense
but that's okay I guess huh XE
I'm catalast I think that's okay it's
all about being laughing I just walk in
circles again
maybe down here
do it why not except everyone I steamed
in valve I don't
goddamnit I'm officially lost it's okay
let's go up here
see what's up here
no no one I need to find objectives
wasn't it tab or something oh here let's
catch the train heading to Burnside make
your way back to the plan okay
maybe this way oh yeah it's this way oh
the platform oh you thought I was lost
but I wasn't I was this tricking video
it's an old trick of mine passed through
the door to Shack
alright and shop down doom pretty good
doing pretty good I only died two times
that is pretty solid in my opinion but
you know we all have our own opinion
about opinions or cutscene movie time
whoa yeah yeah yeah I understand the
case can became too much you weren't
solving cases like you used to
you're talented high strung happens
sometimes
I did not snap someone else killed those
policemen it looks like it might have
been the matchmaker with you that seems
unlikely then why we had allocated rings
difficulties sort things out with all
due respect I don't need a shrink
oh no I know Jesus gonna make out with
you oh no Jesus well what the [ __ ]
yeah what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
Jesus really wants cuddling maybe I have
gone crazy yeah foreshow [ __ ] son
hey hey well why do people keep calling
Merrill Cepero uh Matt Collins
you suck neither what's been bothering
you yes yes to be affected they're not
going to let this drop their present you
must continue with your address do you
understand
fine do you understand yes yes I mean
God no no what do you want from me
Malcolm going on going on you are being
investigated by the FBI for the murder
of two officers that's what's going on I
know time you must go what fine I'm
gonna end the episode here like if you
enjoyed subscribe to come today and I'll
see you what happened activator I try to
make that's remove [ __ ] stay awesome
Ruth girlfriend
my name is welcome to